In the first iteration of GIFMaker,
you may have noticed this create and
save button on the preview screen.
In this next iteration, we want that
button to do something, namely save and
persist GIFs.
Here's what the new flow will look like.
The app opens up to the welcome view
the first time a user opens the app.
But from then on it opens up to
the saved gifts collection view.
With the saved GIFs collection
view as our root view controller,
we follow a flow similar to the first
iteration until we get to the preview
screen, where now the user
is able to save a GIF.
Once a GIF has been saved,
it's added to this collection view.
Eventually you can build up
a collection and persist the GIFs,
such that when we close and relaunch
the app, our GIFs are still there.